the pace of covet vaccinations is
accelerating
mass vaccination centers like this one
at disneyland are being set up the cdc
says
more than 10 million americans have now
been vaccinated with more than a million
shots administered just yesterday but
that's
far below the roughly 2 million daily
injections
recommended by experts our lead national
correspondent david begno
is at disneyland david good morning
good morning california is following the
recommendations from the federal
government to start vaccinating people
who are 65
and older in fact here in orange county
at disneyland
disney has offered some space and
they're even having their staff
help out with getting people in line and
getting them
right up to the spot where they get the
shot they're hoping to do 7 500 people
every day and they started yesterday
thousands of people living in orange
county california lined up at the
disneyland vaccine super site yesterday
3 000 shots of the vaccine made it into
people's arms
on the site's first day being open newly
eligible seniors could barely contain
their excitement and
their gratitude too like 65-year-old
lynn murray
they did such a great job in helping all
these people get
what we need right now get your qr code
ready
but not everyone had a smooth experience
overwhelming demand
actually crashed the county's
registration system it is a similar
story in states like florida
hundreds of seniors there drove to this
vaccine site in desoto
only to be told that 200 doses were
available i've been
on websites on the phone experiencing
the normal frustrations that many have
expressed
with the recent changes to the hhs
vaccination recommendations
152 million americans are now eligible
for vaccination
but operation warp speed estimates it
will take until the end of march
to acquire enough vaccines to immunize
100 million americans
the loss of life from the pandemic
continues to be
unimaginable i'm sorry
and few see the death toll up close like
ken mckenzie
the next appointment isn't until friday
at four at mckenzie mortuary services
in long beach california he says there
are so many people dying that families
are being forced to wait weeks
to have a funeral and then a burial not
only they're crying that they've lost
someone
but they're then crying because they're
on hold for closure
if we're not having a service for that
for three weeks so imagine
waiting three weeks and carrying that
emotion each day in my 34 years i've
never thought i would see anything like
this
ken says most of the time when people
call him they're looking to interview
him to decide whether they want to use
his services or go with someone else but
he says
the situation is such right now that
when they call him the first thing they
say is hey can you help me
later today president-elect joe biden is
expected to announce his vaccination
and economic relief plan as he gets
ready to take over
next week tony relief sounds good to me
david thank you very much